tony hawk pro skater 1 2 is the latest
game to get
a next generation upgrade so today we're
going to be doing a little comparison
between the ps4 pro version and the ps5
version
now what you get on your next generation
consoles is two graphics modes fidelity
and performance
fidelity offers 60 frames a second at 4k
while performance offers 120 frames a
second
at 1080p which unfortunately due to the
limitations of youtube we
can't really properly show off to you
for my money though the biggest upgrade
like with a lot of these updates
is in the loading times it is a
significant improvement
especially for a game like tony hawk
where you'll want to be restarting a
failed run and just get
right back into the action otherwise the
visuals are gonna look primarily the
same
outside of a couple changes to lighting
and color
and much sharper shadows final note for
those of you watching who have a ps5 and
are planning to upgrade to this version
of the game
in order to get your saves you need to
go to the ps4 version of the game go to
the options menu
upload your save and then once you've
downloaded the ps5 version
you go to the options you download your
save and then you have access to all of
your saves and get to watch
all of your achievements pop in if you
enjoy this comparison
we'd really appreciate a like and sub
it's how we're able to keep making
more great videos like this one alright
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you